the only way I know how to be me and
when you have to operate at a high level
I think it's easier just to be
completely yourself then you don't have
to keep up with the lie or the facade
that you've you've kept up but I also
think as a responsibility it's a
responsibility to people with a platform
you know in particular young people are
watching us and a lot of times they uh
glamorize the lives of the famous and
they don't understand that we feel
anxiety and and guilt and remorse and
fear so when they experience those same
natural emotions they feel like
something is wrong because we don't tend
to share the hard stuff I don't think it
helps anyone to put on a brave face and
to pretend to be something that you're
not
um and I never want to be that I've
never been that personal so